were you rebellious when you were
younger it feel you seem like someone
who maybe wouldn't care so much what
what authority figures might think they
express yourself no matter what I wasn't
rebellious it's funny because it's like
when most people go through rebellious
phases in high school I was not at all
rebellious in high school I was a
straight-a student but in elementary
school I did go through it wasn't a
rebellion as much as it was like I felt
completely comfortable standing up to
Authority I was irreverent and did kind
of I didn't think it was weird to like
kind of stand up to teachers we got a
hold of you wrote you had an assignment
which was to write a nonfiction story
right yeah you said you're at your
assignment and I don't know how old you
are when this I was I think I was nine
you were not and your assignment was to
write a non-fiction story and this is
what you apparently hand it in all
capitals which also feels kind of like
what
yeah I'm yelling it right I like this
one to you I guess wrote this to your PE
no no my principal your principal Joanie
and ears principal who you called Joanie
this is a such such a chill school this
is the chillest school you call the
principal Joanie and this is all about
how you don't like PE a bunch of people
to sign it yeah says um we are not happy
with the PE system you have established
we wish it would be we wish we could
have more we would like to have more fun
right and then there's a PS it says PE
is incredibly boring
first of all this looks like a ransom
note if I got this in the mail I would
be called the FBI yeah and I got the
whole class to sign it too that's the
other thing like I not only was like
rebelling myself but I got the entire
class to participate yeah did you get it
any trouble for that I know well I don't
think I got in trouble for that but I
definitely had like a red flag on my
head because like you know whenever I
did anything I would get sent to the
principal's office it would be like I
call her Joey hey Judi how are you
that's so cool I know there's a we found
this today there's a website dedicated
to your eyes you have such striking eyes
and it's called guys with Zooey eyes I
don't know if you've seen have you seen
this I have you put your eyes on famous
guys this one right here there's Barack
Obama I don't think he would have won if
he had oh he'd have doubled this vote I
think there's Hulk Hogan I like Hulk
okay and then of course Guy Fieri who
just looks actually looks no different
he just looks insane and then I had to
try it I want to see what I would look
like with Zoey and then Andy I would
just through Andy in there too
you